the jurogan experience see because that
seems like everything i see on your joe
rogan podcast people don't believe me oh
so that's why
that's why the
because somebody told me not to mention
mermaids
don't mention mermaids i saw mermaid
really yeah when it's the shells africa
you saw an actual mermaid yeah that's
what it was it was a swimming person
really yeah and how long ago was this um
i don't know uh as well sylvans it was
um you think there's like a small
population of mermaids that are out
there but anyway
[Music]
[Laughter]
me and this little french boy and they
said don't they say don't don't swim in
the lagoon after dark everybody's up at
the bar and everybody's and so
everybody's going to go down everybody's
kind of racing night so me and him go
down may him get in the water
from a distance you see something coming
like a [ __ ] missile but it's going
it's going fast and we both kind of stop
and then it turns and it jumps out of
water and it's maybe at least 10 12 feet
long man and do like this and look at
both of us and go oh the water was only
about this deep didn't make a splash or
nothing and then me and him turn the
[ __ ] around we running
and everybody's coming down there
laughing and got the drinks in their
hand we're like no [ __ ] that in the
little boy
in french and his mom is apologizing to
me saying he has a very vivid
imagination no [ __ ] listen
we we saw a fish man and it wasn't like
a mermaid didn't look didn't look
feminine at all look at man a [ __ ]
man a [ __ ] a [ __ ] dude who said
get the [ __ ] out the pool
basically he was like like do you know
aquaman
yeah
hey get out the water
a fish person or a human being it came
out did you have scales
it was kind of dark dark like a dolphin
no but he
he had the back of him was fish the back
of him was fish his head was was
humanoid eyes about so big
then
if you google it the the lagoons of
seychelles
okay and i ain't the first person to see
some [ __ ] really in them waters and uh
the guy the guy who does the horseback
riding you know you can ride horses he
said how old are you and i told him he
says he's from america right like yeah
he says so at this age
pretty much if if you see a turtle and i
tell you that's not a turtle
he's you know it's a turtle you're the
age you know what you say
he says people pay a lot of money at
this resort
he says yes maybe not a good idea to go
around going i saw a mermaid
and he goes my he's saying how long his
family has been fishing in these waters
he says and he's heard some
he's heard some things he says i've
heard some things like what you said
i've never seen what you say you saw but
it's not the first time i heard that and
i said thank you
but basically he was saying that if you
ask me to co-sign that [ __ ] [ __ ] you
right yeah
you're gonna be crazy by yourself so who
told you not to talk about mermaids
nobody told me that
you said that i just said that oh cause
i'm like if y'all don't believe the code
is bear
you definitely won't believe the mermaid
story well i definitely believe the code
is bare yeah i got it from my outfit
please no okay
tony woods thanks for being here man
yeah thank you let me know when your
special comes out we'll let everybody
know yeah i'm sure it'd be hilarious
i'm trying i'm trying if i found it i
would have time to find it it's it's and
and it's it was in the it's in the
lagoons around like you know like how
you know how the island is [ __ ] like
this and like in the lagoon park well
they say they've only discovered ten
percent of the ocean yeah so yeah
maybe he's in the other 90.